this is the political idea of
think and you may think of him at that party
but don't fall for it
because the party has 1 new party leader
Stefan van Baarlo
van baaren has 1 Dutch mother and 1 Turkish Father
with countering racism
is still one of the most important things for thinking
but the party
also speaks out firmly about other things
From the river to the sea
Palestinian will be free
that is complete inverkiezingsprogramma
colored with the Palestinian flag
with the text
this is palestine
everyone can be themselves
only 1 rainbow band in football
or rainbow flags at the government
you should be able to choose that yourself
and should not be forced
okay and the plans for young people
think Want 1 quiet room in every high school
and on religious holidays you should get time off
you also get breakfast and lunch for free at school
and sex education in the lessons
or days like purple friday
they don't like that